I get a feeling there's gonna be a riot
I don't be the news because oh yeah
it's time for twisted hi everybody
thinks tune in sorry that I could not do
it on monday i just got back from China
and so I didn't have time and then I had
to go I forget what oh I had something
going on I just couldn't do it so we're
doing on wednesday i'll put out if you
guys can listen I'd love to have you
guys listen if not no big deal I'm glad
to be back glad to be back I'm going to
be in Las Vegas this weekend Friday
Saturday night 11pm we are at play
Hollywood doing the naughty show Jocelyn
sharp and we got a crazy-ass balloon guy
kevin cole i believe is his name kevin
cole he's gonna be doing crazy balloons
we're giving away fresh lights come out
we're giving away some flashlights of
t-shirts and CDs come to the naughty
show go to naughty show lv com grab them
tickets you and then next week i will be
at alberta canada i will be a mitten i'm
literally going to be the first American
to leave the United States for Canada
I'm going to Edmonton doing the comic
strip ah November 16 through the 20 come
out rock out which [ __ ] out and then
December first I'm very excited the
first week in december i will be at the
comedy bar in Chicago December 1st 2nd
3rd go to comedy bark on for those
tickets college boy good to be back so
not much talked about nothing new going
on nothing exciting just another day in
America just nothing unusual going on
and obviously chaos is broken out chaos
Donald Trump is I'm not gonna talk about
this on because I know people are gonna
be our people get me over this our
people could be over people talking
about Trump like is it's so bad but
everybody's talking about is everybody
gonna be like uh talk about something
else I thought I thought social media I
was like all right elec shall be over at
least and I was so ready for November
ninth yeah and I just don't have to talk
about Hillary Clinton anymore I was like
oh freedom talk about freedom and I was
gonna not and it's just gotten worse
it's just gotten worse it's unbelievable
I just want I'll get into that I do I
won't talk about China i'll talk about
China after this obviously Donald Trump
is our produce it in Pence is our vice
president I do on the realm of shocking
where does this upset fall is it is it
holly holm ronda rousey upset is it is
it Buster Douglas Tyson upset I mean
nobody saw this coming except for the
five people on coke at Donald Trump's
election rally I mean like not nobody
sounds coming like we just learned that
nothing's real the media lost the media
lost all respect how can you believe the
media anymore after showing the shoes up
like it won't boy did her up 10 points
and they're like yeah that came out
that's not real they paid for that
you're like what the [ __ ] what is real I
mean did I remember she was up like 20
24 23 and I'm like this is weird like is
this schism everyone's like well because
the red states are you know the red
states they're done first so that's why
he's getting all that you like okay and
then she never caught up he literally
one buzzard the Buzzard I mean she never
LED in this thing and it is just chaos
and it was like it was really cool
because the cool thing about was I was
asked to do to two shows I was asked to
do well I I was asked to do the improv
election night show and I went there and
there was like 12 people in the crowd
and I still did it because it was like
my buddy Bronson and my friend Christina
Casa Grande and I still did there was
like one gorgeous blonde sitting in the
front and all I could think of like I'd
love to do coke with you if I still did
coke that's all I see girls like oh man
I bet you'd be great to do coke with
like that back of the day I bet you in
[ __ ] 2002 you and I would be great
we'd be doing blow and make a bad
decision but those days are done but up
because I knew where everybody was
everybody's at the comedy store for the
end of the world podcast ah
was like three of my favorite comics joe
rogan bill burr and Doug Stanhope and so
I ran over there man it was really a
completely different energy I mean when
that main room is packed it is like
lightning in a bottle it's lightning in
a bottle man it was like the energy was
buzzing and you just saw I walked on
stage I saw tony hinchcliffe on saija I
saw Dean delran saying like man that's
[ __ ] cool they brought those guys up
so I went in the back and Doug Stanhope
was there and he's our a [ __ ] faced and
that's cool you know he's going through
some stuff with his uh his wife hit her
head she's in a coma thoughts and
prayers even though I don't think they
believe in God you know to bingo I love
duck stamp he started the he started the
Las Vegas comedy scene he's like The
Godfather of it and then I'm the next
one in line and now it's where it is now
but he's the first major name that
really do comedy in Vegas so we've
always had that bond we've really always
been good friends and I you know so I
come up I see him he's got his awesome
like weird kind of like like 10th house
revival pastor used car salesman suit
that he likes to wear like like he got
it off the rack at beale juices house
like it's like it's really he's a
wonderful person and obviously I've
heard what I having a bingo but they
said that the same thing and I respect
that man you know it's like he's going
through a hard time so i got that i'm
just hanging out it was a bunch of
people I hadn't seen forever Oh Greg
chilly who's a wonderful human being who
is who is aa Doug Stanhope's road guy
like he handles all of his road stuff
and he's a wonderful guy met him in
Alaska and you know everybody's got
purple hair so you know it's a good
party and I'm sitting there and I'm
talking to a couple people from vegas
and also night greg goes they're calling
you on stage I'm like wat and my
girlfriend yells at me because I never
she owes you're you're you're one of
them you should be okay go and I'm
totally am like you throw me in a lineup
with all them I'm gonna bang it I'm
gonna hit as hard as everybody maybe
bill burr because he's just a
heavyweight champ I don't think
anybody's hit like bill burr in the
kindle in the country nobody's hit like
bill but I bang with everybody I mean
they're gonna get bigger last me because
they're celebrities and their great
comics I mean it just is what it is I'm
not trying to say anything but I will
hold my own let's just say I hold my own
and so I go out there and dude for the
first hour I'm onstage I am literally
it's like I won a radio contest and I'm
just like come on down to the comedy
store through the end of the world
podcast and the first call it number
five gets to sit onstage with Bill
burned Joe Rogan Doug Santa for an hour
and that's how i felt and i'm like i
gotta say something funny and i said a
couple things in the sow it always
happens for me because whenever i do
panel with my famous friends i'm the
least known guy on the stage and that's
fine that's just life but it always
takes me a little time for people to
realize i'm funny because they're seeing
their heroes and so the cup few couple
things i say get a little chuckle but
then I start I start cooking with gas um
Bilbo was on fire bill burr was on thigh
I mean he was murdering everybody in
every day anything bill bird talks and
punch lines like everything comes out of
his mouth is one hundred percent sounds
like a written bit and his and his
ability to instantly come up with the
best example and a tag is like what
makes him amazing what makes so many
Hinchcliffe great his ability to do puns
I hate to tell everybody that's that's
tony hinchcliffe thing bill bursting is
an amazing ability to to come up with a
punch line the illustrates this point
like something that refers to what he's
saying is you know he's been able to
make references amazing references off
of the top of that and like it's very
funny because I'm a quick draw I'm a
fast gun gun recognizes a gun and that
guy's got the fastest gun out there and
they're so they announced they announce
that weed has been legalized
recreational e and they all just start
smoking weed on stage the place is going
nuts the place is just a [ __ ] weed
house I'm just sitting there watching
I'm not partaking even though I've
really
to smoke weed but I don't do drugs
anymore I just wanted smoke week is like
celebrate good times come on everybody's
getting shit-faced Rogen I know Rogan's
hi face I've seen him when he gets kind
of high it's like I'm not gonna get into
it but it's like it's an interesting
looking for I know when he's banked out
of his skull and he was baked out of his
skull Doug sales run around high as [ __ ]
drunk wasted asking people from the
stage for cocaine he tells Doug Stanhope
is the most hilarious human being you'll
ever mean your life cuz he has no shame
he'll tell any story he told the story
about bingo hitting her head apparently
bingo done too much cocaine she had done
too much blow she had fallen hit her
head had a seizure she's in a coma right
now I need told a story of what happened
apparently she did so much coke people
are flipping out everybody's calling 911
the cops come she has his fanny pack
right she has had this fanny pack with
her too it's like her ba ba you know
bingos Baba is a fanny pack and
apparently it always has cocaine in it
so they're flipping out because they
don't want the coat the cops to go
through it because they'll find the
cocaine so her sisters who r square
edges squares get the fanny pack they go
through it because they're looking for
medical records they find the coke and
it's not a little coke it's a [ __ ]
ton of coke like a ton of coke like like
Pablo Escobar amount of cocaine in this
girl's fanny pack they grab the fey
impact they go back and they're like
Doug we found all of this we found the
coke what should we do what do you think
they did they did the coke they did all
of bingos coke while she's in a coma
from doing coke at the hospital that
live on stage and you just watch the
comedian's go what the [ __ ] except for
me and my dead soul laughing I was
laughing I go that is the most ballsy
story I've ever heard
to my life that's the most ballsy
stories I've ever heard my life um he I
have this theory that the hierarchy of
comedy is this bill burr is the
heavyweight champ he's the champ but the
Godfather is Joe Rogan like he's the
most receive a he's the Alpha of the
group if you put everybody in a room
he's yell I've seen it happen a thousand
times I've been there with all my
favorites in one room he's the Alpha I
and the reason I reason I say he's the
Godfather is cuz nobody ever bust Joe
Rogan's balls nobody does I've never
seen it until that night when everybody
was shit-faced and hi bill burr started
racking on Rogen I've never seen that
before and he laughed his ass off
awesome rectum it was a fine like
Grogan's great Rogan's cool it's like
you know it's like you have your
comedian you have to allow other
comedians to ride that's like brotherly
love that's brotherly love so Rogan
getting racked he's a roegan hit like a
little hat on and everybody calls him
the little rascals hat then Doug sale
starts telling a story about how Doug
Stamper has herpes and how one time one
time Joe Rogan a cold sore on his lip
and he's like so you have herpes here
I've herpes on my dick and I'm the bad
guy and the whole room just kinda got
are you saying Rogan as herpes and it
was like the craziest [ __ ] and Roku told
story about how he had it since he was a
baby and he didn't choose to have it and
everyone's like aha but it was so
interesting to watch people bus Brogan's
balls because you never see that you
never see that and it was just such a
magical time because this will never
happen again this podcast in this
environment will never happen again it
will never because the upset
ab Donald Trump upsetting Hillary
Clinton shockwaves around the world and
people are just people didn't know was
going on I heard Stephen Colbert did a
showtime special and it was the most
depressing [ __ ] anyone's ever seen
because everybody had these sketches
lined up of Donald Trump losing and he
in and they couldn't show so they were
just freaking out South Park's free
writing an entire episode right like its
crate nobody saw this coming and now
people won't accept it people won't
accept his head why are we here who saw
this coming like all of Donald Trump and
Donald Trump's cocaine dollars does
anybody look like they love coke more
than the Trump daughters they all just
look like they love to get gacked out on
blow and I love it um yeah they're great
i don't do die [ __ ] every one of Donald
Trump's daughters have you ever said
that about a president before that you
would bone all the the bush daughters
were like Joey the night like they were
just like they're like that cheeky
banged in college you're like oh yeah
you know she was around she'd like you
know what the bush does look like slump
busters like when you like ham bit late
for a while you had to beg a fatty just
to get out just to get the stink of
desperation off ya you bang a bush
daughter the bush dollars like the party
though of course they do but nobody
looks like a human eight ball more than
Donald Trump's one daughter with the big
teeth and you know I like big teeth you
do like the one that looked i've never
seen her mouth closed I've earned a
mouth because the teeth are too big she
can't get her [ __ ] gums over it like
they look like they love coke they all
look and there's multiple daughters like
how many are there three uh I only know
of two oh there's only two I thought
there was a third like distant one
there's on the distance son yeah and
they sweat like coke don't think they
all look like you they look like every
background guy in wolf of Wall Street
all the background coked out guys who
are just extras they actually gave them
all coke on the set and they were just
coax
wedding it just the whole family looks
like blow I know you know so funny
there's this one porn star she's so
[ __ ] hot her name is juelz ventura
and she does savage porn like she's
she's like super I should be dating like
like prime ministers and third world
[ __ ] dictators hot right and she does
porn and I just sent her tweet
congratulating her on the fact that
she's literally gonna be working every
day for four years because she's going
to be doing all the Molina [ __ ] Trump
porn that's coming out with all the rod
with all the condoms no condom porn
passing and and and the fact that we
have a first lady who literally used to
be a high-end escort no like is there
any is there as much as people hate
Donald Trump is there any president that
represents the country more than a
reality star and an Instagram model that
we're gonna have his the first first
couple I mean that is America right
there [ __ ] fake heat and a chick
who's just I mean dude she is so hot
she's now in the White House I've always
said that in America the easiest way to
move up social hierarchy is to be a hot
chick it's easier to become rich and
famous be hot than it is to be an
athletic man one hundred percent right
yeah sorry ways to get back to this
thing about a real quick about the end
of the world then I'll get into uh the
the actual election Sarah Tiana comes on
I love her to death she's one of my
favorite people on plan I love Sarah I
could not be happier for she was like
she was ready to quit comedy and not
because things were happening for and
now she hit and she's doing really well
and I love her to death she comes on the
podcast on the end of the world podcast
and they threw up and she's great and
she's she started talking about how
Michelle Obama should run for president
since she was a first lady and that just
sent bill off yeah cuz bills whole thing
was like you guys in Hollywood didn't
see that coming cuz you're not in Middle
America you're not
traveling around you don't see what the
words gone I've always said there's a
disconnect between the suits in this
town when the people they're selling to
it's like it's very rare do you have a
sales person who never meets their
customers right yeah like even a
stockbroker selling your suck you going
you meet them and you talk about what
you want to invest right i mean i hate
capitalism I'm not gonna I wanted to be
in the stock market I don't want i think
it i think there's an end game that's
coming people can get mad that same
buddy really do but like you meet you
meet who you're selling to the suits
here are cray television never meet the
people that they're pitching to that
they're selling TV too they only meet
the people within this [ __ ] 20 square
miles of their office and I and I you
know I got to show without magical
comedy central right now and those guys
over there do a great job and they're
doing their best because at the end of
the day the it before you even worry
about what the people are going to watch
you think you have to worry about are
these sponsors gonna like this and then
are the bloggers not going to beat the
[ __ ] out of us on their block then you
worry about what and that's just reality
situations those people are doing the
best again but they live in a world that
is detached from who they're actually
selling to and it's more about them
putting out what they think the world
should be then actually what people are
looking for and that's just my I mean
because that we've seen people say it
over and over again hey man it's I feel
I've heard people say I feel bad for
white guys people have said that out
loud to people I feel bad for white guys
nobody cares about them anymore yeah
what just happened a complete rout this
was a complete revolt by white guys this
is a complete another revolt but anyways
she says that bill starts laying into
her about that Michelle Obama's I mean
just starts laying into her laying into
her laying to her he she's losing on all
cards then I don't know why she did this
she tried to change the topic she goes
to hey man what'd you guys do I now prob
60 the condom porn did you guys vote
or against it and everyone goes against
it she goes I voted for it and dude the
room what not she's like I think porn is
room guys I think porn is ruined guys
I'm like okay there is a point to that
but I go also romantic comedies of rune
[ __ ] chicks they think I should be
running through [ __ ] run through
airports with flowers crying about love
I mean white guys watch way too much
romantic comedies there's too many guys
who think who watch girls you should not
be watching that show if you have a dick
if you're a grown man who doesn't like
other grown man and if you love other
girl man god bless you do your own thing
but if you're a grown man who's in the
chicks don't watch that [ __ ] I just
can't stand this stuff that's not what
that's what girls want guys want porn
girls want that and most guys don't even
want porn sex they just want to see
girls get filthy but most guys don't
wanna be like hey dude let's all run
trains on the stubbly wants that you
know guys wanna pump pump dump sleep
that's what they want get it in get it
out yes please yeah let me do it let me
go to sleep I gotta get the work
tomorrow and pay for all this [ __ ] so
it's just like so she got pounded on
that and then Morgan Murphy came on and
I love Morgan Murphy I think Morgan
Murphy is funny hilarious got a great
ass and I felt bad I said that out loud
cuz it's just like it seems to meaning
but it was Matins love I think she's got
a great ass so anyways she does the [ __ ]
she argues that Trump is a sexist piece
of [ __ ] which I understand but then I
just gotta go but why are you okay with
Bill Clinton's actions and then the
report was he wasn't running but then I
go but in my head I was like but Sarah
Tiana just said that Michelle Obama
should run because she's in the
president's here helping to make policy
but then you're going to say that Bill
Clinton isn't gonna be in Hillary's
they're helping her make policy it's the
same [ __ ] thing man yep that's a
problem we're picketing choosing this
stuff so here we got the elec
tural college and now everybody's math
electoral college everybody's mad
because uh Hillary got more votes
because let's face it she got California
by a landslide and she got new york by a
landslide which are the two most
populated states she's gonna win the
popular vote I get it man there's a part
of me that's [ __ ] yet yeah man the
popular vote should win but there's a
reason they have electoral college and
the reason is we also wouldn't have had
George W Bush if the popular vote yeah I
agreed that too I agree with that too I
agree with that too ah but but that
there was some I feel like she won New
York she won California that's why she
won the popular vote but it was so I
felt like such a blow out that they
couldn't even rigged it like with bush
and gore it was closed so they could
[ __ ] flip Florida and give it to him
I think of it that's why they took
forever to call Florida did you notice
that like they were called states were
like four percent said we're calling it
for Donald Trump like Florida was like
ninety-nine percent in too close to call
and you're like but he's up a hundred
and fifty thousand votes because they
had to wait to see if there's any way
for them to [ __ ] do some shady [ __ ]
and that's my real opinion that they
were just waiting to see if they could
call something and they could now you're
like hey man we gotta get rid of
electoral college why and you look at
the progressive so what's Hollywood all
about I know it becomes a little bit
inside ball if you're listening to this
and I'm just telling you go with me and
I'd like to get Aaron Aaron your
feelings on this okay I feel the
Electoral College is a lot like
diversity in Hollywood where we got to
have everybody's got to be represented
and I'm fine with both now Jay Larson
not jayla who was the right anyway
something I wasn't JLo somebody else
somebody went it for writing gig and
they told them they were the heat they
were looking for a minority lesbian as a
writer they literally wanted a minority
lesbian to be a writer and you take a
look
at at what's going on like tour colleges
before getting this electoral colleges
so that places like North Dakota
Delaware have a say because if it wasn't
that all you would do is campaign in New
York in California Texas and Florida you
wouldn't go anywhere else in Illinois
and Illinois that would be a five states
and you wouldn't give a [ __ ] about
anybody else you would not care about
what North Dakota thinks or Montana
thinks if you didn't give them electoral
votes to give a [ __ ] about so so they
they want to lesbian right I'm gonna go
with a black lesbian I love black
lesbians I literally think God is a
British black lesbian who dj's in heaven
with the best cocaine and nobody has
condoms if somebody gets pregnant an
angel gets their wings that's my opinion
of heaven God is a British black lesbian
but let's say black lesbians let's say
they're looking for a black lesbian the
right on this show what percentage of
population is gay ten ten percent what
percentage of that what percentage of
that population is black ten ten percent
this population is black so you're now
down to one percent of the country now
what percentage of that is lesbian 50 so
now we're down two point five percent of
population you are looking for a writer
to represent point five percent of
population and who is black lesbian
writer North Dakota yep that's North
Dakota you have to have North Dakota in
there everybody's got to be representing
black lesbians have to be represented
even though they represent a sliver of
the population it's the same [ __ ]
thing man you can't cry for this and
then get mad at that this is what
America's build on everybody together
the problem is with everybody the
Hillary camp is yet you bet on a bad
hand you've got a bad hand you went this
is what happened you went to Vegas with
a hundred G's and you are excited to
gamble and you put all your 100 G's on
double deuces you have two twos and you
went all in on it and you'll you
celebrated he started thinking about all
the great [ __ ] that was gonna happen
when you got your big pot cuz you win a
hundred G's in and you lost and now
you're like what the [ __ ] happened your
bet on a bad horse you bet on a bad hand
man you bet on a bad hand should too
many bullet holes too dude she's leaking
and you refuse it was so funny I got I
got yelled at by a friend of mine on
facebook he told me he lost a lot of
respect for me because I put out a tweet
that said this elections between a guy
who says bad things and this is between
election between Anna candidate who says
bad things and someone who does meet bad
things says mean things does bad things
and I got ripped by people Trump has
done some bad things oh but well there's
a scale of bad things there's a scale a
bad thing certainly you know if you're
saying he's done some shady business
deals I would tell you yeah that's bad
compared to given to [ __ ] selling out
our uranium to the Russians who just
pulled out of our nuclear treaty I would
say that's like that's [ __ ] you know
peanuts compared to what we saw in these
emails at Hillary did and the problem is
that people discount those emails even
though people are telling them like
myself and that we agree on everything
but this one thing we agree on
everything but Hillary you think I'm an
[ __ ] because we agree on [ __ ] gun
laws equal rights for equal pay equality
regardless of your race your gender your
sexual orientation or protecting the
environment protecting animals you know
freedom of speech we agree on everything
of that except for this one woman but
because I don't agree on this one thing
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and that's really
what I people told me and people go all
dude Josh wolf goes through that tweet
is dangerous it's it's too its
simplified and dangerous I go dude I
have a hundred and forty characters like
how deep can I go on this tweet yeah we
shouldn't even be doing it yeah you're
[ __ ] you refuse to admit you want to
be right so do writing what
have been right is the tell Clinton your
[ __ ] soul the election from from
Bernie and he should be the one running
and we saw it start when we see it start
when we see it start we saw it start
when he got in trouble for some hacking
memory like hacked in the Hillary [ __ ]
and then it turned out it was an
employee that Clinton had suggested to
them do you remember that happened way
early in the election and they were
going to take away his right to see
polling data and you're like that's when
it started it was Malcolm Fenian dude
she [ __ ] kneecapped him back makaveli
Machiavellian Mecca vein Ian makaveli in
Mecca bellian ok most people listen to
me don't even know what the [ __ ] that is
too yeah and I'm not judging I'm just
like an idiot too I'm just saying what
what is it makaveli there we go it was
just done purposely damn and I didn't
mean to insult anybody's insult dead
listen this I'm very thankful you listen
to it I'm just saying I i I'm barely not
she's a political animal she's a no
she's she's a she's golem she wants the
precious she's a winner she was a win at
all costs yeah type thing add I mean I
you will never see a candidate have both
parties behind her the media behind her
the [ __ ] money behind her the power
bi and lose its I can't stress enough
what upset this is no and everybody
hates Trump and I I don't like Trump but
he he put he basically showed us how
corrupt the media is how corrupt
politics is how dirty everything is I
mean he won it in the faith I like dude
I wouldn't love the scene Trump selling
out arenas Bernie selling out arenas and
a heavyweight fight between those two
yeah but they didn't let us do it and I
got yelled by at the sky that you don't
understand this is how they treat women
who run for politics I go since since
they never did that to Geraldine Ferraro
and since Sheldon for all five five
women have run for vice president or
president michelle bachman sarah palin
this michelle crazy chick who real-time
rip to shred
cuz she says she worships Satan at one
point she was a witch yeah was her name
Michelle something yeah I don't even
remember and then you add aah Carly free
arrow they are far the woman from hockey
arena yeah florina and then you and
Hillary Clinton those are the five are
any of those quality human beings no and
what do you know about for them are
Republican one Democrat she didn't let
other women run no she just locked it
down she actually held women back if you
really think about there's elizabeth
warren would have been amazing that
woman from Hawaii's great i mean the opp
well sure who was ahead of the democrats
for a while duh not barbara boxer who's
the other one out of San Francisco Oh
Feinstein yeah yeah Barbara Boxer
Feinstein could have ran they didn't cuz
Hillary had that [ __ ] down the lockdown
cuz Hillary wanted to be the first
female president and she wouldn't let
anybody run now she's gone ding dong
it's gotta go man and you know what you
guys got to stop [ __ ] just thinking
that you know you got get your media
from the five major networks they're all
owned by the same people you gotta
listen yeah listen man you gotta be have
your mind open dude so here we are dude
i would like to look at I already talked
about that but dude if you wanna if you
want to make history you got to have a
bulletproof candidate Obama was
relatively bulletproof I guess you know
why instead he jumped so quickly forward
yeah he really didn't have a time to get
dirty he wasn't what one term center out
of Illinois yep and they just jumped
they they still have happiness in their
eyes they didn't have to go through the
evil ass [ __ ] and they got right to it
yeah they got the prize early everybody
else has to slug their way through and
the only way you move up as if you show
you play ball hmm and I dude listen at
the end of the day I think Obama is the
best president we've had now there are
things he didn't do well and I will
agree with that the the drone strikes
that's war criminal [ __ ] okay a lot of
people have said about Obamacare well
let me tell you something the high rates
that was that was going to
dude when Obamacare passed all the
insurance companies [ __ ] stock prices
just rose because everybody knew was
gonna because you weren't gonna get
young people join it because young
people think they're invincible they all
think they're x-men and think that was
gonna happen you knew was gonna happen
yeah you could put Santa Claus into the
presidency and he would he would come
out of war criminal it is the evil
inherent evil of the position no matter
who you put in there Santa Claus Captain
Kangaroo to do to hosted Blue's Clues
you name it that dude is gonna come out
[ __ ] evil yeah no matter what
decision you make right or wrong someone
will die yeah thousands problem but the
problem is with Hillary she loved that
[ __ ] yeah we saw it in the email she
goes a lot of Syrians are gonna die are
you cool that you know people they want
to listen she's she was sucking [ __ ]
the Saudis at guitars dick they gave a
million dollars to the Clinton
Foundation you know they gave a million
dollars you got to pay that money back
in [ __ ] favor and that's why we're in
a proxy war right now within [ __ ]
Yemen because we're footwear on where
Saudis [ __ ] strong arm where they're
lethal weapon as we bomb in Yemen
because the [ __ ] Iranians are the
other side there's a proxy war going on
between Saudi Arabia and Iran and
they're fighting over here in Yemen and
we're in the middle of it we're in a war
that we weren't even improved to do like
that's crazy [ __ ] right mmm we've never
been in we haven't been in a war we've
been approved to do since world war two
I mean we proved up we we approved Iraq
war they invade Iraq we prove that
you're we approved Afghanistan yeah you
know you're not allowed to do it ah so
that's it I that's all I want to talk
about this thing's gone longer than I
thought I was gonna go I'm going to do
ten more minutes and we get out of here
um so you wanna hear about China or do
you want to hear about that [ __ ]
snake video I mean I can watch a snake
video I can't I can't go back with you
to China China is incredible dude it's
so far this goes back to the media and
[ __ ] like that how they paint them as
horrible people and yes the
Chinese government is not perfect i'm
not saying chinese government's good
people people disappear and then all of
a sudden we have new organs available
for [ __ ] buying I get that and I
understand that but you want to a big
you wanna know China's like what it's
like to be an ex pensioner it's Vegas
minus the loss well I'm not lying to
they pretty much have their only laws
don't hurt anybody don't murder anybody
don't rape anybody don't punch anybody
if you don't do that you can pretty much
do whatever you want in China they if
you're an alcoholic and you want to die
of alcoholism go to China yeah I
couldn't believe these guys drink like
fish is every [ __ ] night every night
and they drink for free because they're
doing shows everywhere china is
literally like vegas without the loss
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable they
put me on like they put me in a haunted
this hotel and I get there and it's
literally I'm not lying to you a massage
parlor they put me in a hotel massage
parlor a haunted hotel massage parlor
like dude guys were coming in and out I
don't know when dudes are getting
handjobs I've been there which I'm
really i paid for a hand job once I'll
never do it again I'm like why am I
paying for this I do this myself yeah
ever been to a restaurant you will watch
a dude order spaghetti like what are you
doing you didn't make spaghetti at
[ __ ] home while you make it speaking
y-you organs go flaming yawn you want
some SpaghettiOs I'll [ __ ] crack open
a can for you yeah and like I thought it
was haunted I heard [ __ ] and I was like
yelling all right is they buy their like
the door open i'm like hey who then i
realize if they're ghosts they're
Chinese ghost so they only speak Chinese
that's true so I'm yelling to them in
english Hey and they're like Baba I know
Shanghai has a very special chinese it's
very loud and it looks like people are
just yelling at each other but that's
how they talk all the time they're like
a foot away from each other and they
just scream so and this is obviously the
most stereotypical Chinese fake china by
a dog
hang on buggabugga and it just looks
like they're like are you hungry do you
want subway and they're just like
yelling in each other's faces and by the
way everybody in China goes your chinese
is really your fate your chinese is
really bad i go it's fake chinese so
they go we know and it's bad fake
chinese they go you sound like our dads
when they tried in I like what do you
want I'm just trying to give you example
what I heard from the Gulf who have all
probably got carpal tunnel syndrome from
all the angry hand jobs they gave a
Christmas pass a bunch of hand job given
ghost running around so he took me
around like dude and I drank they took
me all the hot spots in China I drink
Chinese coffee at Starbucks I had some
great Chinese food at Kentucky Fried
Chicken where every where did ya it's
everywhere I'd KFC in Cambodia yeah
right and Burger King and tie in
Thailand it's very weird because like I
used to work at PF changs in vegas and
they would always you know they'd always
like all we got this these business
people coming in we're gonna take them
to PF g i'm like why are you taking
Chinese people to a chinese food
restaurant and I get it because you want
to taste your food what your food tastes
like there what's their interpretation
of your food and it was interesting I
dude I can't recommend China enough you
actually go there going can I live here
I could Wow yeah they showed the World
Series games in China I was watching it
at all the ragin Cajun Cajun food I did
stand-up place called jalapenos which
was a Mexican restaurant Wow all the
chicks are hot all the women over there
just talk about sex non-stop that's all
they do everything is enough I don't
know if guys well another too many guys
there's too many guys if you're a chick
over there you're [ __ ] baller
everybody [ __ ] loves you um what else
I want to but I think that's it dude I
don't think I got a lot talk about why
do I feel like I just erased that mother
[ __ ] i did look at that you piece of
[ __ ] you piece of [ __ ] okay um so that
was china's crazy
china was [ __ ] i mean like do they took
me to these ye gardens which are like
two thousand years old she like it's
cool to see that [ __ ] everything
translates man but then we go so they
have tier cities right one tier two tier
three tier like your main cities like
Beijing Shanghai Hong Kong those are one
tier see because they're the most modern
three-tiered supposed to be you know
hickville guess I went to shaman it's a
third tier city guess how many people
live in xiamen 6 million 7 million well
and that's a hick town yeah just imagine
Myrtle Beach if had seven million people
and they all Chinese [ __ ] that's what
shaman was like it's a beach town of 7
million people well so when you live in
China and you're there on a work visa or
something you have to leave the country
if you're an expat every 60 days yeah
you have to leave like kind of play tag
with another country and come back in
Asia yeah you have to do so my friend
Barney Riviera who's a comic out there
he's a Mexican in China and he literally
gets hired by this mexican restaurant to
just hang out and talk spanish on the
microphone it's literally like you know
it's like when they hired chinese people
to work at Chinese restaurants out here
is to say that make it authentic and he
had stuck so he has to um he has to go
to Taiwan for like a brief just tagged
Taiwan and come back yeah so me and this
female comic from portland and kiri a we
have to go on our own he literally just
told us find your way to the hotel why
we go to Taiwan now I'm lucky curiae
talks a little Chinese I talk none I'm
like I don't know where the [ __ ] were
going so they're like hey we got find
this hotel we're staying in a huge hotel
the problem to hotel it's in the back
alley this jano tells in a back alley
nobody knows we're there restaurantes
I'm or the hotel is like have you ever
been in la just walking around some
girls how do you know what Baba boys are
you like I'm like I don't know where
that is I've lived here for 15 years I
don't know where certain things are in
this building yeah well the chai dude
they don't know where this back-alley
hotel is this guy was standing in front
of the hotel we asked him do you know
where this hotel is he did not know
where the hotel was standing in front of
the hotel he sent us down the alley he
was in front of it that's so funny so
they put us in this taxi the girl woman
goes do you know where this hotel is the
woman goes yes the female taxius Curia
is a feminist she's like see we got a
female to do it females now what's up
this woman had no clue where she was
going I like how did your feminism now
so we go she just like we drive to like
this main area the downtown of shaman
we're like we're lost what do we see a
starbucks I'm like just go in there
let's just go in starbucks and i felt
i'm gonna end up living in starbucks
imma beat tom hanks from terminal I'm a
being Mike my phone doesn't work I can't
get on the phone here I'm gonna end up
living in in [ __ ] the starbucks in
xiamen never ever ever leaving this
place probably getting curie a pregnant
raising a family here never leaving the
starbucks ever in my life just going
outside why they closed when they reopen
go back inside that's not because I no
clue where the [ __ ] we were little did I
know that we will a block away from our
hotel dude it's crazy dude and I'm an
old man like everybody wants to go out
cuz I know like you want to go out go I
know you guys are gonna be out till four
or five in the morning no I want to go
to [ __ ] sleep I'm three days back I
still haven't caught up on my sleep oh
yeah I'm sick soil right it's unfold all
right I want to talk about lizards i
watch x-men
achal if she watched that no that is
unbelievable that someone thought that
that movie was ok to put out I'm telling
you it is the worst movie I've ever seen
in my life but Jennifer uh what's her
name Joe it's just JLo oh she's so
[ __ ] hot yeah it's so unbelievable
but I don't even gives you like who's a
Margaret what's her name that was in
Suicide Squad Margot Robbie margot
robbie is she the worst actress you've
ever seen your life I haven't seen too
much with her in it to be honest you
didn't really know I didn't even see
that movie it's bad yeah it's bad I mean
they really blew a chance to do
something amazing um margot robbie is
what happens if you took an Instagram
model and gave her a less actor's career
she is the she is so hot then nobody
gives a [ __ ] that she cannot act she
cannot act does she even Instagram model
hot though she is pretty [ __ ] hot
dude I mean she ruined she's ruined two
of two of will smith's movie I don't
know why he he's done to movies with her
the first movie did with her was the
first time in all of his life and like
he was on a roll like like 10 number one
movies in a row he didn't move hers the
first time they didn't get number one
movie it was unbelievably it was
terrible yeah 10 minutes a night what
was it called oh god it was something
stupid I think yeah it was just dumb
there was one word yeah also I won't
tell everybody was yelling at me about
be on my phone during the end the world
podcast I was checking results I wanted
to see if prop 60 past that's all which
it did thank god i'm really upset the
death penalty thing didn't pass I mean
dude it's not about as well no they its
appeal yeah it did it got repeal at the
end of the night yet did hope there's no
death penalty in California are you
telling me that I think so look it up i
think you're wrong i think it passed it
should dude we don't need a death
penalty dude i would rather have a
million
focus was the name of that shitty movie
yeah it was horrible her acting was so
bad but she's so hot some [ __ ]
directors like I'll give a [ __ ] I gotta
look at this chick like magic that's how
high you are you are your your your
facial structure is so symmetrical that
people want to give you millions of
dollars to work with them Jennifer
Lawrence can act yeah Margot Robbie
cannot well guys how was this why I felt
this was the better one of the last 3
i've done i think the last two before
this were just weird hi de great time if
you're in Vegas come see me man by
Saturday night imma be on Jason L show
tomorrow subscribe to my youtube channel
youtube.com backslash Sam Tripoli come
see me dog get at me dude I'm Andy I'll
see you guys should take care love you
guys child pieces into pieces and the
parts are busted on your greatest
thinking at you sinking in the rotten
gutter now is nothing left but
everything to gain oh I step to those
domains that have them grow and so gel
form of the resistance if you